also wenn du das geschaut hast dann
musst du dich nachher schwer betrinken
um einigermaßen wieder zuversichtlich in
die deutsche zukunft zu schauen punkt 1
deutschland ist ein land das jetzt
eigentlich eine faktische
vollbeschäftigung das problem in
deutschland aus meiner sicht ist dass
wir dabei sind das eine der
bedeutendsten volkswirtschaften europas
in eine planwirtschaft umgebaut wird wo
der staat sich immer stärker in die
wirtschaftliche tätigkeit einmischt ich
bringe nur das beispiel autoindustrie da
werden die der europäischen union die
flotten kontingente vorgegeben also die
bürokraten bestimmen was die unternehmen
produzieren dürfen und das in einem
industrieland aus imbissen und das in
einem land wie in deutschland aber wenn
ich mache das einfach die schreiben da
sein doch was dort vorgegeben wird warum
hatte für mich diese fokussierung oder
diese diese sich festbeißen diese
klassen kam frage die er sicher für
gewisse leute fans eine bedeutung hat
die den mindestlohn empfangen aber das
hat für mich nur bedingt mit der
realität zu tun und das ist aber das
bringt mich wenn ich meinen letzten satz
noch sagen darf ich glaube einfach in
über alle teile gesehen wir haben hier
in diese debatte eine themen verengung
und wir haben auch eine themen
vermeidung gebraucht patrons
angesprochen wir kommen auch darauf
meine es gibt themen die die leute
glaube ich viel mehr beschäftigen als
das was heute angesprochen
das ist das ist eigentlich kein
klassenkampf thema wird dürfen ich meine
wenn der wenn der cdu kanzlerkandidat
diesen eindruck erweckt er müsse da
linken entgegentreten wenn es um
mindestlohn geht und auskömmliche
lebensverhältnisse überhaupt leben kann
ohne zwei jobs auszuüben dann verdrängt
und vergisst das eben dass dieser
sozialstaat in deutschland von der cdu
geschaffen worden war eigentlich die spd
die hat ja wie jahrzehnten nicht
mitregiert also dieses wirtschaftsmodell
stammt von der cdu teilweise von der fdp
die hat aber nichts zu beigetragen so
die cdu war immer die csu noch mehr eine
sozial partei wie kann man sich bei so
ner auseinandersetzungen an diesem amt
derartig in die ecke drängen lassen was
jetzt passiert im armin laschet machen
müssen weil es war ja so ein bisschen
die situation zwei gegen eins man hatte
das gefühl oder shorts und annalena
baerbock wir haben sich verbündet gegen
den armin laschet die wissen bei den
themen soziale gerechtigkeit umwelt
all diesen dingen da haben sie die dinge
auf ihrer seite können immer sagen ja
wir wollen zwölf euro mindestlohn und
armin laschet will gar nichts und der
ist der böse also was hat er denn tun
soll er hätte sich überlegen sollen wie
ein angebot bei einem thema an annalena
baerbock macht er muss mit ihrer gier
und sonst nicht mehrheitsfähig also kann
er sie nicht nur angreifen sondern er
muss klar machen sie ist nicht gegen die
natürliche partnerin von olaf scholz das
will olaf scholz gerne hat er ja auch
schon gesagt das ist auch seine
partnerin und da kann er nicht daneben
sitzen und so tun als hätten sie mit ihm
nichts zu tun
während der fdp-vorsitzende saß ja nicht
dabei also war ganz alleine er braucht
sie aber also muss man sich etwas
überlegen in der klimapolitik
beispielsweise und muss sagen bin ich
mit ihnen einverstanden ich schlage nur
einen etwas anderen weg vornehmlich den
und den aber bei den ehrgeizigen zielen
die wir jetzt vereinbaren müssen bin ich
mit ihnen völlig einig und dann
formulierte ein konkretes angebot kann
er doch er muss auch nicht unbedingt
gegen den mindestlohn von 12 euro
argumentieren das ist doch immer noch
ein erbärmliches geld für die leute die
ist bekommen sollen das ist doch nicht
viel die werden doch nicht gepampert vom
staat die werden geradezu über wasser
gehalten dagegen muss man nicht
argumentieren wenn man die die
sozialstaats vergangenheit der cdu im
kreuz hat und lade er aus wie eine
sanktion mehr zb für hartz4 empfänger
dass er das neue modell was spd entgegen
aber er kann nicht gegen die zwölf euro
argumentieren in wahrheit das ist so
dass es so klein ist doch nicht ich fand
es nicht schlecht argumentieren zu sagen
in manchen bereichen ist ja auch viel
viel höher und muss dafür sorgen dass es
tariflich mehr bleibt und ich finde
schon ich finde die die sg da haben die
tarifvertrags vereinbarung aber das ist
ja kein gesetzlicher mindestlohn
gesagt hat ich fand da hat er definitiv
den stärkeren punkt gemacht als einfach
zu sagen wir wollen zwölf euro was
wirklich übrigen zwölf euro gelten ja
nur für die leute die keinen
tarifvertrag haben das weiß auch jeder
also eben ein habe ich
vielleicht als ergänzung ich bin ja
unternehmen ich habe eine eigene firma
ich musste jeden monat löhne bezahlen
löhne bezahlen und wenn ich so eine dvd
anschauen da muss ich einfach sagen
keiner diese kandidaten vielleicht laut
steht natürlich noch am ehesten aber
keiner dieser kandidaten hat war
wirklich für die unternehmer gesprochen
es ist was ich vermisst habe das geht in
die richtung was niemand gesagt hat wo
ist hier der vertreter er sich
kompromisslos jetzt im wahlkampf für
freiheit einsetzen die wirtschaftliche
freiheit für meinungsfreiheit und auch
für den rechtsstaat freiheit und
sicherheit also die klassischen
eigentlich deutschen tugenden wenn man
so will das ist alles immer in richtung
staat immer mehr zum start
staatseingriffe das war die ganze
debatte und nicht einmal ausdauer
theilig die enttäuschung von julia
görges konnte hier diese diskussion das
gepräge geben und wenn du deine so eine
diskussion nicht führen kannst hier
kannst du deinen land will
[Musik]